hey Vsauce Michael here and the year
6009 will be the very first year since
1961 that a year when written and
hindu-arabic numerals can be inverted
and still look the same
but you and I probably won't live long
enough to enjoy the year six thousand
and nine human lives just aren't long
enough we will miss out on that one of
their cool future events will we be
missing well first of all you and I will
probably be gone before the completion
of the time pyramid inventing Germany it
will eventually be a pile of 120
concrete blocks but the builders are
only adding one block every 10 years
since beginning in 1993 they've added
only the first three at this rate the
pyramid will be completed in the year
3000 183 the final block placed by our
great-great great-great-great-great-
more than 30 greats grandchildren but
even they will miss an opportunity to
frolic and play safely in the Chernobyl
exclusion zone the zone of alienation
where radioactive contamination from the
1986 disaster will remain at levels too
high for safe human activity until not
the Year 4000 not the five thousands not
the six thousands it will finally be
safe probably in the year 22,000
possibly within our lifetimes but
definitely within the next 1 million
years stars like Betelgeuse and edik
Arena will explode in brilliant
supernovas visible from Earth I'm bummed
I'm probably going to miss out on these
events because for a few weeks it will
look almost as if Earth has to Sun
despite being hundreds thousands of
light-years away their supernovas will
shine brighter than the full moon at
night and be visible even during daytime
but the real sky show comes in three
point seven five billion years our
galaxy is full of stars viewed from the
surface of the earth they look like
little drops of milk in the sky which is
why we call it the Milky Way galaxy but
all galaxies are named after milk milk
lactose lactic Galactic galaxies and
every drop of milk in the sky every star
that you can see is inside our galaxy
the Milky Way but there's a blurry
distant shape this one it's not a star
it's not a cloud of gas in our galaxy it
is an entirely different galaxy the
Andromeda galaxy and it's two and a half
million light-years away from our own it
contains twice as many stars as the
Milky Way and it is coming our way
headed toward us at 300 kilometres a
second faster than a bullet now right
now the sky looks like this in two
billion years Andromeda will have
approached so closely that people will
look up at the sky and see this in three
point seven five billion years the night
sky will be like a scene from a
science-fiction movie or an awesome
desktop wallpaper incredible and kind of
scary after this scene the sky will
literally be glowing with the birth of
new stars as the Milky Way and Andromeda
collide mixing up into a brilliant
cosmic tie-dye this simulation shows how
Andromeda might collide with the Milky
Way but keep in mind that you are
watching billions of years pass every
second these galaxies are moving fast
but they're also
and covering even huger distances they
will collide in the future but within
the briefness of a single human life
they appear almost frozen unmoving a
couple billion years after colliding the
cores of both galaxies will be married
together in a bright glowing Center
earth now a stepchild to what was once
Andromeda part of a new bigger family
called milk dromeda it would be so cool
to be alive to see our galaxy colliding
with another but don't get all FOMO
consumed by a fear of missing out
because whatever life is around then
we'll have plenty to envy us for they
may have spectacular nightly views but
secretly wish they've been born in our
time to experience and say the beginning
of the internet they will actually miss
out on a lot of things because the moon
moves one centimeter further away from
Earth every year 600 million years from
today the moon will no longer be close
enough to earth to completely block out
the Sun future humans or descendants of
humans will therefore miss out on a
chance to ever see for themselves the
beauty of a total solar eclipse from the
surface of Earth
long before earth dries up Niagara Falls
will dry up well not the water part but
the Falls part every year the rushing
water of Niagara erodes the rock at the
top of the Falls one foot backward by
the year 52,000 it will have eroded all
the way to Lake Erie and our progeny
will have no Niagara Falls to enjoy
granite has an erosion rate of about one
inch for 10,000 years
so certainly by the year seven million
Mount Rushmore especially its faces will
no longer exist and because they slowly
get pulled in or ejected into space in
50 to 100 million years Saturn will no
longer have its lovely rings so life on
Earth in the future might have awesome
supernovas and galactic collisions to
look forward to but they probably won't
have Niagara Falls Mount Rushmore total
solar eclipses or Saturn's rings they
also won't have you but you have you
except not all of it
babies don't begin to form episodic
memories right away meaning that you
missed out on
you don't remember two of the most
seminal events in your life your
conception and your birth but you can
experience a bit of those moments right
now first of all when was I conceived
dot-com lets you enter your birth date
and get back the week your parents
probably made you happen as well as the
number one song and the number one movie
of that week which may have also been
involved light travels quickly the most
quickest in fact but it can take a
photon
millions of years to escape from the
interior of the star it was created in
through nuclear fusion it takes time
just like your own gestation in your
mother's womb newly conceived photons
struggle through a dense stellar jungle
of atoms and molecules and electrons
that absorb and re-emit the photon
taking a little bit of energy from it as
it randomly rolls around like a pinball
sometimes after thousands or millions of
years it's random walk finally leads it
to the Stars surface where it pops out
into space in a way is born a lucky tiny
tiny tiny percentage of the photons that
reach the surface of a star find
themselves on a path that will intersect
with earth and if you are lucky those
photons will end their journey by being
absorbed onto your own retina if you
enter the date of your birth or the
approximate date of your conception into
this online calculator you can find a
star that is as many light-years away
from Earth as you are old when you look
up at that star today you are seeing
light that left the star the very month
you were born or photons that left that
star and entered space when your entire
body was just one cell space is really
big and your life is very short but
space is so gosh darn big you don't have
to miss out on everything and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you